je vais continuer d'essayer de
convaincre dans les semaines qui
viennent de l'option que je partage mais
je le répète il n'ya aucune
dramatisation dans la situation lors de
la conférence nationale du parti
communiste les délégués et conseiller du
parti ont rejeté la proposition de
pierre laurent de soutenir la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon parti
communiste supporte pas qu'on se mêlent
de leurs affaires donc si je veux faire
une bêtise et qu'à faire ça m'en mêler
donc non je ne m'en mêle pas pour être
milliardaire est immorale parce que tu
une accumulation absolument
disproportionné qui rend fou celui qui a
lui-même milliardaire puisque une fois
qu'il a un milliard 1 2e l'abus n'est
pas supportable
le débat qui a eu lieu avant-hier à
tourner pour beaucoup entre une forme de
règlements de comptes ou de mises au
point entre six personnes qui ont tous
été tout était pardon dans le même
exécutif et qu'ils avaient besoin
visiblement de procéder à quelques
ajustements dans le cadre d'un repas de
famille ou taper sur nicolas sarkozy ce
soir je dois taper sur l'un ou sur
l'autre j'ai exprimé les convictions
fortes vous sortez du débat vous êtes
souriant pourquoi olic je pleure en plus
que la sarkozie il essaie désespérément
d'exciter
le les plus dures de ses soutiens et
donc tout ça c'est tactique électorale
et pas à la hauteur de la situation
on m'a dit que je ressemblais à des gens
mais qui commence à peine l'acteur de
pretty woman d'adresser votre film
préféré
non pas du tout vous me prenez pour un
neuneu on tourne
imaginez pas que je regarde la télé pour
me tarde de voir dans un miroir
alain juppé lui a reçu un soutien
symbolique ce week-end en déplacement en
corrèze il a rencontré la fille de
jacques chirac claude chirac pense
qu'alain juppé a exprimé la décision qui
a été la sienne d'être candidat il a été
peut-être pas le premier mais un des
tout premiers à s'en réjouir et est à
dire combien il était heureux pour pour
alain juppé est pour la france un format
photo d'identité alors certains ont
trouvé vintage d'autres ont dit qu'elle
était austère quel message vous allez
vous avez voulu envoyer aux électeurs
j'espère que l'élection ne va pas se
jouer ce raid affiche nom françois
hollande a déclaré un jour que j'étais
une tombe
c'est vrai je suis une tombe et monsieur
elkabbach contourner qu'une tombe on
l'état vie voilà il faut dix ans entre
le temps d'une décision publique et le
temps de sa réalisation
mais c'est toujours à 10 ans que nous
devons réfléchir pourquoi ça s'est passé
dans les bois après il faut aider qu'il
faut dix ans pour réussir je me dirai
simplement que cinq ans suffisent pour
échouer au prix parfois j'ai envie de
tout envoyer bouler et quand on dit là
pour la 25e fois à est ce que vous allez
fendre l'armure et ont fait chier avec
votre armure parce qu'il ya longtemps
que les fendu dans tous les sens par mur
le méga fichiers soulève de plus en plus
de critiques le conseil national du
numérique organe consultatif a demandé
ce matin sa suspension immédiate
comment se fait chier peut être aussi
très intrusif si on change de
gouvernement
et moi je pas une confiance
instinctif comme ça et naturelle dans ce
que pourrait faire un brice hortefeux ou
l'extrême droite avec un tel fichier
demain cette fois c'est officiel c'est
yannick jadot qui a gagné le droit de
représenter europe écologie à les verts
à la prochaine élection présidentielle
et la remporter le deuxième tour de la
primaire devant sa rivale michèle rivasi
sprint final aux états unis donald trump
a traversé cinq états pour faire cinq
meetings tout ça en une seule journée ne
s via innova finalement pas poursuivre
hillary clinton dans la sphère des
emails qui empoisonnent sa campagne
depuis des mois elle est protégée par un
système corrompu affirme-t-il c'est un
système totalement corrompu ça fait
longtemps que je le dis vous ne pouvez
pas analysé six cent cinquante mille
nouveaux e-mails envie jours voir barack
obama bien même en renfort et aux la
moquerie au sujet du candidat
républicain
privé de son compte twitter par ses
conseillers pour éviter les dérapages
si quelqu'un n'est pas capable de
maîtriser son compte twitter alors qu'en
sera-t-il pour les codes nucléaires
l'élection de trump serait un drame un
drame pour le monde parce que cet homme
est proprement irresponsable et
dangereux vouvoie seriez donc il arrive
ce qui représente tout ce que vous
combattez je remercie je ne suis pas
américain
alors ce sera l'apocalypse annoncée
selon vous drague ce serait un immense
risque ce serait des zones mais de toute
façon c'est déshonorant pour les états
unis qu un histrion comme ça atteignent
45 % ça interpelle beaucoup pour ce qui
était supposé être la plus belle
démocratie du monde
or il se trouve que si madame clinton
l'emportent ce n'est pas si rose que ce
qu'on nous dit mais mme clinton c'est la
candidate qui veut faire passer le
traité transatlantique le taffetas vous
savez on a fait passer malheureusement
le trait avec le canada là ce serait le
traité du boeuf aux hormones des ogm le
taffetas elle l est pour tromper contre
car ce n'est pas la fidélité qui
l'étouffent c'est nicolas sarkozy qui
parle de vous je vais je lui ai répondu
dans un petit texto très simplement je
ne suis pas un homme politique qui te
dois un mandat je ne suis pas un fait à
la vie d'un souverain nous avons un
désaccord politique majeure et je pense
que je peux apporter plus dans la vie
qu'une m'a donné ou là rien la lecture
du livre dania j'étais tellement
consterné que
j'ai consacré une partie de mon
intervention à cela en disant devant le
premier ministre qu'à mon sens l'article
68 la question de l'article 68 supposer
une roue de brides mentalité c'est une
cinquantaine d'euros voilà comme ça vous
le savez je suis arrivé à la conclusion
que au delà des questions d'opportunité
politique ce qui est dans mon camp des
gens qui pensent que hollande est
tellement faible qu'il faut surtout pas
lui faire quoi que ce soit il est très
bien comme ça il est tellement faible
que c'est le meilleur candidat possible
moi je pense qu'il ya des questions de
fond qui sont posées et l'honneur de
déclarer ouverte la coop mad de ré
politiciens corrompus et leurs intérêts
particuliers ont régné sur ce pays
depuis trop longtemps
aujourd'hui c'est notre fête de
l'indépendance ne fait pas d'erreur nos
valeurs fondamentales sont en jeu dans
ce scrutin
les premiers électeurs à se rendre dans
l'isoloir ont été les habitants du petit
état du new hampshire
le résultat est déjà connu il est
symbolique et ne présage en rien de
l'issue du scrutin
c'est hillary clinton qui l'a emporté
face à donald train pour les deux
candidats seront à new york pour la
soirée électorale
c'est aussi ici qu'ils ont tous les deux
voté ce matin donald trump aux alentours
de 11h hillary clinton
un petit peu plus tôt vers 8h30
l'arithmétique des minorités devrait lui
donner la victoire mais c'est pas tout à
fait sûr parce que elle a quand même
fait beaucoup de gens delà des tests en
vérité franchement tout ce qu'ils
voulaient
les âneries la brutalité tous que ce
type peut sortir et quand même
invraisemblable
donc je voterai quand même pour hillary
clinton mais met en effet tout ce
qu'elle représente mais assez détestable
plein de super nerveux mais plutôt
enthousiaste c'est une immense
opportunité à quelques minutes près il
n'aura pas vu ses militantes féministes
seins nus floutés par la télé américaine
elles sont venues dans le bureau de vote
du candidat républicain dénoncé sa
misogynie la liste des des promesses et
des malédictions d'ailleurs de donald
trump elle est juste considérable des
malédictions pour vous ce sera une
malédiction s'il était élu demain à
écouter ça poserait un abord ça nous
poserait un problème majeur à nous
européens par les états unis et la
france et d'une longue histoire rien
entre nous le lien du sang des jeunes
américains sont morts pour notre liberté
jamais on peut l'oublier car je fais
confiance au peuple américain pour
savoir quel est le choix qui correspond
le mieux aux valeurs aux principes à la
liberté à cette relation avec la france
est avec l'europe
françois hollande le président de la
république a regardé le début de la
soirée électorale à paris et maintenant
il est allé se coucher il dort mais un
de ses plus proches conseillers doit le
réveiller par téléphone dès que les
résultats de l'élection américaine sont
connus et c'est un new york est la ville
de donald trump la terre d'élection
d'hillary clinton que les deux candidats
à passent leurs soirées électorales à
deux kilomètres l'un de l'autre c'est au
javits center que la démocrate prépare
son discours un centre de congrès aux
airs de grandes verrières possible
probable clin d'oeil au plafond de verre
qu'elle entend briser ce soir hillary
clinton
moi j'étais hier à philadelphie avec les
familles obama et les familles clinton
parce qu'il avait barack et michelle
obama et hillary et bill clinton et même
chelsea clinton et on avait franchement
l'impression que c'était bon ça y est on
a gagné on peut se le dire bravo
bienvenue dans le club il arrive donc il
est allé se coucher en pensant que
hillary clinton allait gagner largement
et bien pour l'instant visiblement ce
n'est pas le cas donc iris d'avoir une
surprise en se réveillant marque clinton
est donné vainqueur dans en virginie et
dans le colorado ça fait 22 grands
électeurs pour ces deux états donc c'est
important
attendent pour l'instant c'est plutôt il
tombe dans l'escarcelle de notre
effectivement est le dernier en date
c'est donc l'ohio l'ohio l'un de ces
états clés qu'on attendait avec
énormément d'impatience car il a du
poids regardez ce 4,8 et tout à l'heure
hillary clinton
quel que soit l'âge quel que soit le
scénario de ce soit merci pour tout ça
sent pas bon la victoire quand même
quand on lance victoire également de
donald trump dans le missouri
avec dix grands électeurs pour cet état
là du côté d'hillary clinton à la traîne
donc pour l'instant victoire au nouveau
mexique
cinq grands électeurs victoire également
de la candidate démocrate dans le
connecticut
eh bien non
c'est un séisme ce matin que nous vivons
donald trump est au seuil de la maison
blanche
c'est une voix un temps une onde de choc
un coup de tonnerre hier soir j'ai
félicité donald trump et j'ai lui a
proposé de travailler avec lui pour
notre pays
j'espère qu'il sera un bon président
pour tous les américains
je promets à chaque citoyen de notre
pays que je serai le président de tous
les américains
un moment difficile dans les relations
entre l'europe et les nations unies dans
les états unis mais le président
américain est librement élu et mérite le
respect de l'institution européenne ce
prix là aussi en face de lui la réalité
et c'est un homme d'affaires
la réalité il sait composer avec elle et
il sera donc s'adapter évoluer tirer les
leçons changé pour la cellule
diplomatique de l'elysée avait pris
depuis de longs mois
contact avec les équipes d'hillary
clinton mais pas vraiment avec celtes de
donald trump
c'est une non pas vraiment une surprise
mais c'était une possibilité
j'ai eu ce sentiment en lorsque je me
suis rendu à plusieurs reprises ces
temps ci aux états unis et françois
hollande a même eu des mots très durs à
l'encontre de donald trump confiant je
cite que il n'a jamais que le
milliardaire américain lui donnait je
cite le haut-le-coeur paris cinéma très
imprudent de la part du chef de l'état
d'avoir de telles critiques pendant la
campagne
écoutez je crois qu'il n'a pas été le
seul d'abord un devons regarder en face
cette situation
et là encore prendre conscience des
inquiétudes qui sont provoquées par les
désordres du monde dans tous les peuples
y compris le peuple américain à gauche
on perçoit le danger
jean christophe cambadélis met en garde
sa famille politique
la gauche est prévenue continuons nos
enfantillages irresponsable et ça sera
marine le pen ouah c'est le plus beau
coup de pied au cul qu'on puisse donner
au monde des bobos des médias de la
politique des sondages le peuple
américain a parlé
sachons nous aussi en tirer maintenant
toutes les conséquences très licitation
nouveau président des états unis donald
trump et au peuple américain libre
marine le pen qui veut voir dans cette
élection inattendue
un bon présage pour elle même marc
lorach la france et l'europe soit des
messagères de paix de concorde sur la
scène internationale pour éviter cette
montée des nationalismes à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés aujourd'hui l'extrême
droite de manière générale et par tous à
des niveaux extrêmement élevés en europe
et on l'a vu avec le bric site on le
verra je l'espère probablement demain
avec notre allié du fp aux élus à la
présidence autrichienne un mouvement des
peuples qui veulent être entendus contre
la mondialisation débridée contre les
traités de libre échange qui détruisent
l'économie et l'industrie